this program is brought to you by Emory
University
you
specifically the procedure that we're
talking about today is a method by which
we address irreparable rotator cuff
tears which means those types of tears
that in the past we haven't been able to
fix directly to the bone by filling the
gap or filling that defect in the
rotator cuff with a graft a tissue a
human tissue if you will that you can
attach to the native rotator cuff and
then use that as a bridge to fill the
gap and reattach the continuity of the
rotator cuff to the bone
advantages of the graft material our
number one it is human tissue number two
it precludes the need for big dual and
triple incision procedures when you use
a muscle transfer but number three at
least on early outcome it improves pain
scores and improves range of motion in
our patients we have a series of sixteen
patients now who have undergone the
procedure 15 of those patients now have
got longer than one year follow-up and
the specific characteristic we see in
all these patients is number one an
improvement in range of motion and
number two a market decrease in their
pain score
every one of our patients in our
relatively small series was satisfied
with the procedure would recommend the
procedure to a friend or family member
and would have the procedure again under
the same circumstance and I think when
you look at patient satisfaction I think
that's the highest acid test that the
patient's actually felt that they
improved that their lifestyles improved
and that they would recommend the
procedure to a friend or family member
or have the procedure again the
preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University